[Music]
I got a call from an agent who wanted me
to go and audition for a new film called
The Empire Strikes Back
that was how I became a stormtrooper
this whole thing started because this
guy in our office is really into Star
Wars we all have one right after some
pretty serious internet sleuthing I've
tracked down this guy my name is Ralph
Morse he was a stormtrooper in Star Wars
episodes 5 & 6 that's the Empire Strikes
Back and Return of the Jedi I II was in
the get my shuffle ready sequence I
decided to carry my gun left-handed
sidesaddle
like I was carrying a shotgun in the
West and it's in the film you can see it
so we're talking about what it felt like
to be a stormtrooper and for the most
part that means what it felt like to
wear the costume I think all the
costumes were the same size and the
original model I think was about 5 foot
10 some of the guys are terribly tall or
terribly short found the costumes
unbearable and once you're in this thing
you can't really get out of it you
couldn't really sit down at all you have
to kind of lean to one side and if you
if you wanted to go to the bathroom you
needed to prepare yourself you needed
more than 30 second warning okay but
there is the helmet the iconic helmet
the first helmet they gave me I couldn't
see through the damn thing at all the
other problem we had were our boots they
had soles but they had no tread in the
soles so you would slide all over the
place I don't know a stormtrooper who
hasn't at some point falling over oh
alright so it wasn't very glamorous but
it's still cool right cuz you know Star
Wars
[Music]
you
welcome photon warriors
I invented laser tag about 30 years ago
that game we all grew up playing high on
pizza and soda on a weekend night it was
invented here in Dallas Texas by this
guy George Carter laser tag might never
have happened if it hadn't been for one
particular movie the movie star wars I
was sitting at a theater in Las Vegas
and watched them going up and down the
halls of the ship shooting lasers at one
another getting interrupted there George
there are no actual lasers and laser tag
yeah I found out early on that there was
a rule against shooting lasers at people
there was a federal agency it didn't
while that ah back to the story I
thought it put it in some sort of
context and make rules and we've got a
great game then George is an inventor he
has a lot of patents actually about a
dozen Oh a couple of his other
inventions motorized surfboard the first
modern bumper boat off-road vehicle
called the Snoopy but we here in Dallas
to talk to him about a game he called
Photon my first choice was laser tag and
my trademark attorney said that's too
generic he'll never be able to get a
trade name on that so we had to come up
with another name but it was a little
different than laser tag is today right
we promoted running and actually being
very competitive george's ideal game was
actually designed for 20-something year
old men not pre tween birthday parties
at family centers conceptually it had
three main tenants first
yeah the arena was very important we had
some facilities at very large arenas up
to 20,000 square feet the second the
field needs to be symmetrical so that
you had an equal advantage or no
advantage to either team and the third
ya mercy of environments of special
effects lots of music lots of lights
lots of fog that that really got you
into the game so what happened well
photon toys in 1986 were the number one
boys category
but it was actually kind of an error
because it lowered our demographic age
George doesn't play laser tag anymore
call him a purist yeah I got other
things to do - I've got other hobbies I
grew up playing laser tag at a Family
Center and having learned about photon
yeah it seems cooler but I like laser
tag too
[Music]
when the young kids on the street found
out that I was working on Star Wars I
was like a god to them
those kids are now parents they've seen
the movies throughout the years there's
always in the back of the mind like all
I remember playing with it Falcon I
remember playing with the x-wing and the
TIE fighter
to understand that you have a small part
of that kind of bigger world is is
pretty cool
[Music]
my name is Mark Boudreau and I've been
fortunate enough to work on Star Wars
toys since 1977
amazing thing about Star Wars I don't
think it's really ever gone away it's
always been there vehicles has been sort
of what I really am the most passionate
about TIE fighters x-wings Rey's speeder
I have always built models built planes
cars so they said hey Mark why don't you
go ahead and start working on the
Millennium Falcon
that's like sure why not
[Music]
Elaine Falcon gives more than just a
machine it really is a character that
helps save the day it's more than just a
hunt to John he wanted to be able to
provide an experience that could extend
in the film so when you went to go see
the movie you come right back and you're
playing with Luke you're playing with
Han you're playing with Chewie and
you're able to relive everything that
you saw on the film
long after I've gone to the force
wherever that might be this product will
still be there grandkids from now will
hopefully still be enjoying Star Wars
and we certainly want to try to do our
small part into making sure that that
continues
[Music]
this is Alan Dean Foster hi I'm Alan
Dean Foster and he's a science fiction
writer yes I am he might even be
familiar with one of his books in 1975 I
worked with George Lucas and wrote the
book version of Star Wars no way yes way
this is Alan Dean Foster's office this
is the view from Alan Dean Foster's deck
this is how Alan Dean Foster met George
Lucas they were looking for someone to
do the book version of this science
fiction film that no one knew anything
about I was asked by my publisher if I'd
be interested I said yes and that's how
the book came to be it was the
opportunity of a lifetime
but it came with one pretty big caveat
George's name would be on the cover and
I couldn't admit to having ghostwritten
the book so he lied for a long time so I
had to lie to people's faces for 20
years
this is liar Alan Dean Foster's library
he's written a whole bunch of
novelizations Star Wars of course the
first three alien films The Chronicles
of Riddick Clash of the Titans and most
recently the force awakens and a lot of
other books too since the first these
are spells vanishing into the outer
that's maybe the least interesting thing
about them their secrets that will
forever remain unrevealed
these are all indeed Foster's
weightlifting trophies this is Alan Dean
Foster's benchpress okay here's Alan
Dean Foster's front kick got that from
Chuck Norris not a joke
here's Alan Dean Foster with his camera
he's recorded his travels on six
continents I'm stuck on this one planet
I'm determined to see as much of it as I
possibly can so how does a world-famous
crazy prolific sci-fi writer manage to
keep this up and still find time for his
writing well to stop learning is to
start to die didn't dizzy Darius arrest
me say that yes he did
[Music]
you know John Ford only needed one take
[Music]
people could understand that this is the
kin to the scariest thing you've ever
done then they'll start to understand
why we're so addicted to it when I put
the goggles on first thing I'm doing is
trying to calm down
it totally puts you inside the drone you
just forget where you are I'm Conrad
Miller also known as ferati and I'm a
drone racer
I started in September 2014 and that was
like the ground floor of all the
activities I've partaken in motorcycles
and flying drones are on the same level
in terms of intensity oh it's cool when
you have a hobby and you can do it and
you love it but when you can share it
with your kids I mean that's just you
know that's just like what it's all
about I think okay so props again flying
and racing with sorrell has just been a
pure joy he's a good kid and he's a
talented kid and I think it comes easy
to set any kid like that because they
don't feel the pressure that adults do
good landing come in and hat this is
harder than anything else I've done and
it's because when you're when your
nerves go your fine motor skills go kids
don't care there's having fun and they
just learn much faster in the course
LA's at the Hawthorne mall which is
abandoned it's been abandoned since the
80s I believe and it looks like a place
where you would go if there was a zombie
apocalypse
[Music]
when I go into races feel like I put a
lot of pressure on myself to win you
know I want all of my practice and all
of my time flying to show for something
I was flying fine I wasn't nervous but I
was just a little too high and crashed
you like almost the ceiling you like
[Music]
everybody is just working really hard to
be the best at it and it's just gonna
get tougher and tougher I take that 180
good ok you did
flying with roll now it kind of gives me
an opportunity to look at it from a
different perspective because I can
coach him ready mm-hmm
[Music]
he's aware enough to know that he gets
to do these things that most kids don't
get to do he's flying a drone which is
this groundbreaking thing we hit each
other you hit me what are you talking
about we hit each other you know his
parents we don't always feel like we do
enough I brought him in a drone racing
and he knows he's lucky and he knows
he's fortunate we got a kid oh you're
going pretty quick and you know he's
just he's grateful for everything that
he gets
[Music]
[Music]